[Music]
I've never seen a movie like this
we're revving to give you everything we
got
we got something special so let's
celebrate that it's the end of the road
so we're going back to the roots of Fast
and Furious
come Graves
then I go what kind of trouble can we
get into this time everything is bigger
better and hits you like a right hand of
the jaw
it is True Entertainment on a massive
canvas you're about to learn all about
fear with a new villain with new Stakes
real steak I hadn't played a villain in
probably 10 years all right dorks what
are we blowing up I wanted to bring
something to the lineage that hadn't
been done yet he just comes in guns
blazing you guys are going to hell
that thing is really one angry guy
really well dressed to face off against
Tom and his family you had to be a
certain psychotic he's coming for you
with everything
there's something coming and Dom knows
it I can't think of a better time for
him to be at a Crossroads never accept
that
out
we're all feeling unsure at the moment
even down
this is Sarah we haven't been as
successful as we're used to seeing this
team be and that's kind of scary
this sets the stage for something larger
so it's unfamiliar territory that's the
problem with having such a big family
how do you choose the ones you save
I really am looking forward to the
torettos being back together again we're
firing on all cylinders
is it exciting yes
it's trying to tear us apart is it
nerve-wracking hell yeah this is the
magic of fast Let's Race it's showtime
we go it's the beginning of the end it's
the sum of everything we've loved in the
Fast and Furious Universe here they come
it's exciting to be the piece in the
puzzle of something that's so very
important pop culture I do suggest for
the audience out there to prep it's a
big one for a saga to be complete it
must have an end it's bittersweet that
here I say more meaningful
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are building This
Magnificent family
what's going on in that head of yours
something a little piece of it he said
dad they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear boom
you built such a beautiful life filled
with love and family I never got that
chance
you stole that from me
my few sure
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
beat by piece
[Music]
[Applause]
he's coming for you with everything
everything what's the plan dog I'm not
sure anymore
[Music]
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
[Music]
never accept death
he's trying to tear us apart
[Music]
today I race to stop the bloodbath
that's the problem with having such a
big family how do you choose the ones
you save
looks Grace
[Applause]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime we go
game recognizes game
[Music]
I'm coming for you son
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]